you graduates are coming of age in
an amazing time as americans we enjoy
more freedoms and opportunities than
citizens in any other nation on earth
so my american dream is pretty simple my american
dream is just not living paycheck to paycheck
we have the chance to get an education and work
hard and give our children a better life you don't
go to college you you don't get a job like that's
the only way you can make a living for yourself
the challenge for our generation is to create
a world where everyone has a sense of purpose
from a pretty early age i knew
i wanted to be an orthodontist
what has always been certain is the ability to
shape that destiny my mom was a teacher i just
ended up falling in love with history and went
down that track you will be happy you will be
successful and you will make a difference in
the world congratulations on your graduation
a college degree is a signal attend the best
possible university you can get into you'd be
wrong to forego a college education the return
on a college education has never been greater
what it is a signal of is i am able to speak
a certain way and understand a certain set of
cultural tropes and this group of people maybe
not so much financing college is very tough for
millions of americans tuition has gone through the
roof post-secondary education is now the largest
source of consumer borrowing behind mortgage
loans so many families are borrowing to the teeth
and the thing that we say to
these kids is do this shtick
in high school and it will get you into
college and then we say now do it again
and it will get you a job they fell into
a trap our society is created for them
student loan debt has been steadily increasing
affecting approximately 44 million americans
the cost of getting a college education
is having a lasting effect on graduates
it's just so natural like everyone does it this is
good debt thirteen thousand dollars can turn into
25 000 easily there's a good return on investment
i'm paying all these bills and i have nothing you
did this to chase the american dream that we all
cherish people are alive but not living this is
not the way the american dream was set up you know
here i am 36 i have a million dollars in student
loans every piece in the system did what it was
supposed to do and the victims are 17 years old
the stories all come down to one theme how has
this happened to me when i did everything right
i remember mad when i was you know 17
a guy walked in from a local college there
in the city of fayetteville and said hey
if you haven't started thinking about
college education you are you are late
and if you really want to be successful you have
to go to college because if you do not
go to college you will not be successful
i didn't know how to process it my entire young
life i was never taught the proper education
of what i needed to be successful i was just
told go to college you will be successful and
if you have to take out student loans that's okay
everyone is doing it and i became like everyone
the culture in the last three to four
decades has dramatically shifted it used
to be that we said education is important study
something so that you can further your career
it moved from that to where education was
permission to play you weren't going to be
valid in the economy unless you had a four-year
or more degree not only is it necessary
but it's like a guarantee that you're guaranteed
to be more successful and so you have to have
this because a degree is the answer society has
rules and the first rule is you go to college
you want to have a happy and successful life you
go to college if you want to be somebody you go to
college if you want to fit in you go to college is
a four-year college degree still a good investment
i mean not surprisingly the principal you think is
a good a good investment for a couple of reasons
one a student is going to earn a million dollars
more over their lifetime career if opposed if
they didn't have a college degree they'll be more
nimble they have lower rates of unemployment even
robert johnson said they're going to live longer
because they're likely to have better insurance
okay we set the table in such a way that we doomed
millions of parents and kids to take the bait
when we elevated the pursuit of a
four-year degree to here we inversely
relegated a two-year degree or a community college
or an apprenticeship program or all those other
things down here higher education became a
thing everything else became an alternative
there was some studies that came out and said if
you have a college degree you will make this much
more in your lifetime that became the marketing
slogan for higher ed which is if you come do this
you make more money the shift of a public good
turned into a private good i'm getting my degree
so i can make more money for me then the markets
got involved and this thing was not something we
all invested in like roads or police or fire
departments it became a way for me to get rich
the cost of college has grown faster than the
cost of energy and the cost of real estate the
cost of health care all of it somehow we got it
into our heads that it's priceless and we've told
an entire generation of kids if they don't borrow
whatever it takes then they're going to enter into
this crazy rat race hopelessly disadvantaged
so you had a 17 18 year old kid being told
to sign on the dotted line or else his parents
aren't cautioning him not to do that guidance
counselors aren't saying hey take a breath
be careful nobody is i think where this
really becomes a crisis is millions of people who
faithfully pay their student loan bill every month
where that debt is having an enormous implication
on their lives and their communities things like
the ability to buy a house save for retirement
what career you choose even if you're gonna start
a family it's this unintentional consequence of
just living in society and being surrounded by
everything that says spend and have a certain
lifestyle and it's okay to borrow and to go
into debt and just make sure you can afford the
payments they're just following the normal path
normal ended me in the back of my car
because i didn't have nowhere to sleep
normal ended me in the ymca washing myself
because i didn't have a home to go to and
take a shower before i even
turn 19 i'm 35 000 in debt
i was that young kid thinking
about committing suicide
i was that young kid wondering
how am i going to eat
it was during that season in my life that i
decided that i'm i'm sick and
tired of being sick and tired
i'm tired of not being able to have the options
what can i eat what can i do where can i go
and so i got myself out of debt
learned a lot about money learned
a lot about life all right anthony
had to lose some friends had to better myself
and i said when i get out of this i want to be
in front of young people and help them go after
their dreams but make sure that their dreams
do not become nightmares and when i look at
this table i see dreams but if it's going down
the wrong path i also do see future nightmares
and so i'm excited to be here with you all
tonight is to have a conversation about
your life and what you are experiencing you
all are about to step into the real world
what is one thing that you're feeling about
graduation so once i get out of high school
i gotta make sure i get the right steps to
make sure that whatever i do going forward
can put my kids in a better situation
than i am does that make you fearful
though are you nervous about that yeah god i'm
a teenager you know i make bone-head decisions
so like my small decision can play a big
role in my future hey but you know what
at least you admit that right unless i'm a
teenager i'm gonna make some dumb decisions
what is one decision you're scared of making
i want to enjoy my life to the fullest
cause i live for now and then i also got to live
for the future so you don't know which one you
want to choose my mom tells me all the time to do
what makes me happy you support me 100 um but then
i also have my dad um he tells me look you have
to pick something it has to be something that's
high paying because you have to feed yourself you
know and we're in a society today where you can't
just not go to college or like well you can but
it can be a little rough of course growing up your
parents always tell you you can do anything you
want to do you can do anything you put your mind
dude if you work hard in high school and you
keep these good grades and take these classes
you can go anywhere you want to go
well they don't tell you that there's
a 180 000 price tag attached to it so do
you think college is the only way you can
be successful in life yes always going to college
is like a safety net no matter what you do in life
no matter what dreams you chase if you have
a degree to fall back on you're always safe
so
my game plan was the game
plan that everyone else had
i'm gonna apply to get student loans
i always thought everything's just gonna
be fine everything will sort itself out
college was always in the picture older brother
went to college older sister went to college so
me being the youngest also go to college
and get the best i can for myself
for that first year it was 24 000
i didn't work i played three sports so
to me it was really easy just say this
money will just take care of itself i'll
make enough money went off to school and
didn't really worry about it for a year until we
had to do it all over again free money free money
get out the notes that we started on before
we're gonna keep going over values and beliefs
and things that we have in our society
that tell us what we can and cannot do
and so on from there i met
josiah through mutual friends
we were only dating for a couple months and he
just brought it up and i didn't even think twice
about it like everyone had it like that's fine
whatever and i don't think it really hit me until
like the week after we got married we got
a decent amount of money from our wedding
and that instantly like went straight to like
all of our bills and then like it was gone
everyone in the pictures and they're so happy
holding their diploma walking across the stage
by the time the graduation ceremony
was i had realized it's not this happy
go lucky time i had taken out about a hundred and
ten thousand dollars in student loans interest had
been gathering the entire time that had ballooned
to 125 000 after four and a half years of college
it was something that i was not prepared for it
was an avalanche coming down on me i had a total
of 11 separate bills coming in the mail for 870
some dollars that i was going to pay per month
student loans on the table for you yes
man you jump straightly yes bro i mean
i'm not the first i'm not gonna be the last
like because that's the only option i mean
technically no my thing is whenever you wanna
do something you gotta take the good and the
bad with it yeah so like my thing is if you want
to be real successful you might have to take on
the debt but it's you going to work hard to get
out of that ditch but how much that is too much
what are you really yeah like that's the whole
thing when it comes to the student loans so like
what what does you feel like it's an enough risk
for you yeah and in life like everything sucks
everything has like a backdrop everything has a
trade-off you're never gonna get the good only
you're just choosing what sucks less yeah that's
true i know people that are planning to die with
that debt like they're only paying interest
i'll take the bloke like give it to me you know
so you would hold that burden for the rest
of your life yeah paying off student loans
hundreds and hundreds yeah like when you won
something really bad you got to take all of it
this is probably one of if not the most important
financial decisions in your life and i think a
lot of this stems from this unfortunate thought
that we don't need to worry about student debt
because it's quote good debt there's something
about like the word student being before the
word loan that just makes us think about this
differently and like differently in a very bad way
the student loan problem has reached epidemic
proportions the curve on the growth of credit
card debt even though it's been ridiculous
has been much more gentle than the curve on
student loan debt it's gone to a mushroom
cloud in terms of the mathematics on it
the problem is is that you don't register
emotionally that it's money i mean when you borrow
money to buy a 20 000 car you have a completely
different emotional experience than if you write a
check or put down twenty thousand dollars worth of
benjamins right there you having them you have an
emotional experience that you do not have when you
just sign and go i think i can make those payments
it's the same thing happens with student loans
there's a whole lot of people who have a big
target on your back who view you and your ability
to take on a ton of debt as their chance to get
rich college tuition has risen enormously over the
past five decades why would someone pay for this
well everyone seems to agree that graduating
from college is a guarantee to a better life
so it's no surprise that the student
debt level has risen exponentially
as people pursue their shot at the american
dream but is the payoff really there
well when the student loan program was first
started by the government it had really good
intentions students could only borrow up to a
thousand dollars a year for school the expectation
was as students completed their higher education
they would in turn contribute their knowledge and
skills back into society and the money for all of
this came directly from the us treasury but as the
demand for higher education grew so did tuition
now the government had to open up the student loan
program even more so they brought in the banks
that meant the government didn't have to foot the
initial bill anymore but they still guaranteed
the loans if the borrower couldn't pay it back
so the banks they were getting paid
one way or the other and on top of that
they got to collect any and all interest from the
loans in business this is called making a profit
so fast forward tuition is still rising because
the demand for college wasn't slowing down
and the banks they couldn't keep up this is
where the government stepped in and created
the student loan marketing association more
conveniently known as sally may as a government
sponsored enterprise they were designed to funnel
money into the student loan program they would buy
the loans from the banks which allowed the banks
the cash flow to issue more loans and over the
next two decades sally may became a major player
in the student loan market but in 2004 sallie mae
cut their strings from the government and became
a fully private company and this meant they were
a real business a business that exists for one
thing to make a profit this is where the student
loan program went from being a public good to big
money actually this isn't even a program anymore
it's an industry
the real mail in the coffin though came a
year later when sally may convince congress
to make private student loans nearly impossible to
discharge through bankruptcy this has resulted in
growing default rates record amounts of interest
accumulated and dragged out repayment plans
that never go away now we're left
with entire generations of people
trapped in student loan debt who took it on in
hopes of making a better life for themselves
because that was the original goal of all this
but it's companies like sally may naviance great
lakes thea osla nelnet and countless others
whose pockets are overflowing with the money
your future was supposed to be built on
so with over 45 million americans sharing
this 1.6 trillion dollars of student loan debt
the question still remains hey guys it's
lacey and i am broke as [__] 200 000
172 000 in debt i went to a regular ass day
school i have only paid off seven thousand
two hundred thirty one dollars and eleven cents
how much interest have i paid in thirteen years
nineteen thousand thirty dollars
and twenty seven cents holy sh
i got in there one day and it said your loads will
be forgiven if you die well that's that's nice
so i feel like my time in college wasn't
really the ideal picture that i had at college
i feel like college is supposed to be fun
and the time that you're away from parents
and rules and can make your own decisions
but my college was pretty much filled with
how am i gonna make sure i'm stable
my view is like it's not the end of the
world it's normal it's life to have dead
everyone has debt everyone has it so it's
fine brush it off don't worry about it
when i got my final financial
aid report and i seen
how much more money i needed you can't
start class if you don't have a zero balance
i had to do something i couldn't
get that amount of money from home
i talked to the financial aid advisors that we
have at our school and they introduced me to loans
i did look at it as it was
investing in myself like it's okay
but then once i realized i had to continue to
take things out it was like okay wow
this is like adding up very quickly
it became a thing of like
dreading the fact that i'm gonna owe
so much money when i get out of school
that is when it like hit me the hardest it's
like you don't want to have to being dead
and so you try to comfort yourself
with the notion that it's normal
but you don't want it so it's like a constant
like dissonance and conflict going on through
your whole collegiate career because you're like
yeah i'm excelling as far as i'm getting a higher
education but at the same time i'm going to be
just like everyone else working to pay off debt
the weight that people feel from this decision
they haven't even made their first rent payment
on an apartment they haven't had to have their
own bank account for a lot of students like their
prefrontal cortex isn't even fully developed
yet and yet we're saying do you want 50 000
in student loans that's a lot to put on
an 18 year old especially when you have
well-respected adults working at banks or
admissions offices saying you know hey this
is a great thing just take out this loan it's no
big deal people shouldn't leave college in chains
from the decision to get an education that
helps them contribute to society that is a good
thing it's really sad to see people struggle as a
result of this great decision to get an education
and add another one to add another one to the
list yeah they said some of these other bills
were going to be a little bit lower but you never
know so we might even have additional stuff too so
come back on groceries yeah so if we can change
like what do we need we need about 60 bucks 80
bucks so if we can choose you think oh i have a
house we have a car we have jobs like we're fine
we're the average american but we weren't making
ends meet we were living paycheck to paycheck and
i thought i made a decent salary we get the taxes
this month it puts us at about 20 short so if i
go donate plasma like another time that's another
20 bucks or so yeah depending on which one it is
we are on our way to lima to donate
plasma uh it's something that i
do usually every tuesday and
thursday after football practice
split outside linebacker's wide out widen out
have to stay in still quarterback is still
your guy because if they do a crossbow
i'll be home till about eight or so but
gotta make this a little bit extra money somehow
that money i make during the month or donating
is a big difference in my life people say like
i go through a crazy schedule but you know
i've left courtney at home for the last
12 plus hours i worked in works and works
and i worked at a job i didn't like but
i had no choice like i have
student loan payments to make
i didn't make enough money to pay it off
in 15 years like the plan they wanted me to
they're gonna take me 30 years to pay off i
took up credit cards when i was on college
because that's what you do i still had a
car payment at that time too i was broken
i'm paying all these bills and i have nothing
i want you to be successful i want each and every
one of you all to go after the american drink but
i got to ask you this question what is one thing
that can stop your dreams dude say it again did
say that one more time did my man you gotta take
debt off of the table i'd rather take six years
to graduate debt freed and freedom graduating
four and i spend the next 30 years paying back
my sick lunch let's be real if all of you all
went to college didn't listen to my advice today
two of you all will graduate from this table
with a hundred thousand dollars or more in debt
studies are showing that the average person takes
them 20 years to pay back their student loan debt
let me go deeper studies are showing that y'all
right here young people when you graduate college
the number one goal in life is not to
get your dream job number one goal in
life is when you graduate college it's not
to go out there and buy you a nice car and
it's not to go out there and buy a house and start
a family you know what the number one goal is for
college people who are just now graduating
pay off sickness is that the american dream no
the number one mistake i see with your generation
is you take a kids approach to an adult decision
it's funny talking with my mom and getting
her story of you know i went to college
for four thousand dollars and thinking to
myself that's cool it's not that cheap now
growing up we were more in the lower middle class
a single mom who has two boys you could tell
that we didn't have an endless supply of money
for college i ended up opting to go the business
route i saw what the financial situation was like
and realized if i could create a business and
grow that and then be able to give back how
much more of a difference would that make
if i could fund 20 of me to go to college
u of m in minnesota was my big choice
it's a very large substantial campus
and you get this sense of pride you know walking
into that situation knowing that this is where i
could be cutting my teeth for going out into
the real world so one day go to the mailbox
i got in that's what i wanted i was totally set
on going there i'd done everything i needed to
up into that point basically i could coast out
my senior year right i made it to the next step
that's the funny part they don't send
the tuition with the acceptance letter
that letter also had shock you open
it up you look at it and 22 000 a year
at that time i'm driving
a car i paid 600 bucks for
i was totally ready just to dive deep into debt
because that's what the journey looks like right
that's what everyone expects it to
be and i was gonna be one of them
what college are you going to i haven't like
got my financial package from duke yet but
duke is my passion why is duke your dream school
um i've been to the campus i've toured and i fell
in love with it you fell in love with like the ex
like the classes the people there the overall like
experience of being there their connections how
much is duke gonna run you um yearly about 75. oh
it's undergrad so i'm still thinking about uh
yeah that's 300 grand yeah no for a degree yeah
what about you nyu really nyu yeah why is that
your school because it's like saturated with music
artists with with producers with opportunities
just out at every corner for music in particular
how much is it uh 75. oh my gosh 75 000 i'm
gonna reach for what i can and if nyu is it
then i'm gonna reach oh my gosh i was so
serious please stop stop don't leave us
okay so i toured buffalo back in
november and i don't know i feel
like it'll be a lot like high school as
far as like arriving like there like i
know my parents talked about like college
was like the best years of their life and
died and so i feel like the experiences that i'm
gonna get at college are gonna be like unmatched
so you're going all the way to buffalo state
just to have an upgraded high school experience
um yeah keyword upgraded well if i wanted to sell
a college to the normal group of semi-unmotivated
semi-uninformed people i would
start with the football team
i would move on to the parties
i would then go on to uh shiny pictures
of people at graduation we are we are
i wouldn't mention student debt i wouldn't
mention all the hours you have in between class
because most colleges aren't good
at helping people through that
picking a school is a complicated process between
applications and essays and costs and visitation
and the stuff out there on the web it's it's
just overwhelming the average person doesn't
know what to look for because this isn't their
world and then all of a sudden you get thrust
into it and it's information overload and how
do you synthesize it into something that makes
a whole lot of sense the new 30th edition of
best colleges was just released this morning
and we've got it brian kelly is editor of u.s news
and world report good to see you again brian kelly
this is getting to be an annual visit we like
it if you were to ask me what's the worst thing
that has happened to higher education in the
last 20 or 30 years i would say unabashedly
a fledgling magazine decided to start ranking
colleges which schools will have the greatest
chance of giving you the american dream the usual
suspects i have to say princeton harvard yale
columbia stanford are the top five the whole
world wants to go to these places education is
a brand now it's a label that's an industry one
of the things u.s news and world report measures
is the percentage of people the college rejects
that the more people you reject the better college
you must be i always look at their alumni they
are they're very loyal alumni people who go to
princeton love princeton they give it money they
come back they stay engaged with the school that
makes a difference and then they came with this
ever-evolving matrix of points really important
things like your reputation how other people think
about you it turns into a higher ed arms race it's
like nikes versus gucci they're both shoes they
both work the same but one has more value because
of the name some colleges figured out if they
made their dorms nicer or their gyms fancier
more people would want to come what's up with
their dorms what do they have beautiful campuses
yeah 10 different residence halls there's a food
service it's pretty awesome if more people wanted
to come they discovered that u.s news and world
report would rank them higher do you accept bribes
only very large ones i have been lobbied by some
of the finest people in the world if u.s news and
world report ranked them higher more people wanted
to come if more people wanted to come they could
charge more because their piece of paper was
worth more so the ratchet kept turning and it
kept turning and it kept turning the parents are
demanding the college students are demanding it
you have to build it otherwise they won't come
because your college isn't good enough the idea
that you can spend four years not living at home
going to class three hours a day yeah that's
the definition of privilege wherever you came
from best campus food i mean it is fabulous wow
so let's be really clear you shouldn't go to a
famous college there's no reason i hope you go
to a great college but i also know that some of
the cheapest colleges in america could be great
if you make them great if you use your time there
to have a series of experiences to change your
life and other people's lives because that's what
you get you get four years of freedom and leverage
what are you going to do with it because
if all you're doing is saying i'm going
to give up four years of my life and all my
money for a piece of paper at the end well
it doesn't make sense to pay what
you're currently paying for the paper
what really was apparent to me was how
much debt can be that ball and chain on
your ankle when you actually hop into the real
world once you can change that mental state of
debt actually doesn't have to be an option i can
do this a different way there's a newfound freedom
that comes with that going forward with
school i knew that i wanted to pay for it
later on in my senior year when i went
and toured wisconsin lutheran college
i went to the school with the mindset i'm gonna
hate this i was thinking am i shorting myself by
going to a small school will i be able to get the
job i want to because i went to a no-name school
everybody knows university of
wisconsin-madison the badgers
how many people know the wisconsin
lutheran college warriors
as exciting as d3 football is i knew
we weren't gonna be known for that
but then when that tuition bill came paired
with some scholarships that i earned in high
school meant i wouldn't be going in my first
year that was an eye-opener i'm convinced that
most of the mistakes around college are
simply college choice it's it's simple
30 years ago the difference in cost of a community
college a state school and a private school was
not a lot and the difference in what you got 30
years ago in terms of the quality of education
was a lot the weird thing is is that the quality
of education has come up on the community college
so much and on the state school so much
that they're almost all three parallel now
but the cost went dramatically different but
here's the thing a lot of people get the basic
knowledge of business the basic knowledge of
a communication the basic knowledge in i.t
field at a community college and get a really good
career out of it information is just much more
accessible now than it was 30 years ago to the
average person so let's talk for a second about
whether you should go to college at all given that
every single course at mit is available online for
free given that with motivation you could cover
four years of college coursework in a year that
there are ways to cobble together what you would
learn in college and even show up with a degree
without going in the front door without paying
full price and the giant shift that's happening
is that the people who are hiring what they want
from you is not that you went to a school with a
better reputation or at least a better football
team what they want from you is the real skills
creativity honesty directness leadership
resilience and i think we've got to strip
away the easy and fun part stop rewarding it stop
confusing it with a useful signal and instead
get back to the hard part which is how we're
going to be productive generous human beings
i'm not i'm not really going to college to get my
degree i'm going to get the knowledge so my plan
was to go keller's right that's like yeah harvard
for innovation it is yeah and then i was like i'm
set but then two schools here have animation
programs i was like you know might as well
i go and check out lipscomb's animation program
and it's the the professors are disney animators
so it's like what i'm getting here in my
home state and home city and like for free
wow instead of getting into like 400k debt right
it's like why would i not you know wow yeah so
you turned down the harvard of animation to come
here turn on the channel okay you're banking on
student loans and work if not it sounds like you
may not be going to school that's the reality
i've come to face this year you still may not
be able to go to school or your dream school
i wouldn't be able to be comfortable at school
but if i don't go to my dream school because i've
picked my dream schools to be the schools that i
would be happy at that i would be comfortable at
why it's like it's the price you pay for
certain things in life because i could skip
out on college and go work a full-time job
won't have any debt but i won't be happy can't
come up with 13 000 a year so you can't no no
i honestly didn't know how i was
gonna pay for year number two
you go through the first year of
bliss but when the tuition bill hits
and you get that letter in your mailbox
that says tuition is going up for next year
no one wants to pay more money for school
i was fully prepared to take a gap year or do
anything to avoid having debt my second year and
continuing on college tuition can now cost as much
as 50 000 a year but luckily one woman says she's
figured out how to get a college education for
free christina ellis earned half a million dollars
in scholarships and is the author of confessions
of a scholarship winner welcome christina nice to
see you a lot of times whenever people hear that
i won a half million dollars in scholarships they
sometimes assume that like i just got to pocket
anything that i didn't use and they're like
where's the car that you bought and it's like no
that's not how it works that being said a really
cool thing about pushing for a lot of scholarships
is that you can actually get a refund check if you
live off campus i would actually get like a ten
thousand dollar check each semester to be able
to pay for my housing and my books and meals and
transportation so winning scholarships can allow
you to have a lot of freedom and flexibility with
how you live your life while you're in college
what are your thoughts on scholarships are
you all currently applying for any right now
yes and it's like i don't know where to look
right and it's really overwhelming because
you hit so many dead ends it's like 10 million
scholarships it's just it's overwhelming it's
strange to the library and got scholarship
books in their garbage like i'm trying
i was aware of scholarships honestly they were
just a hassle just too many non-guarantees in
that when i could be working because most of them
only range from like 200 to a thousand dollars
and that doesn't even put a thump in
how much tuition is at most universities
i think it's great to have a conversation
about scholarships your freshman year because
it gives students time to develop
a resume without a lot of pressure
that being said a lot of students think that
it's too late to apply for scholarships if
they've already started college and that's just
not true there are scholarships that are available
for students all throughout their college
experience the gap is really there's a lack
of financial education inside of our schools and
in two this is a lack of wise counsel along this
journey and we're not taking the time to teach our
young people to step back and to do the research
if you spend two hours filling out an application
that allows you to win a thousand dollar
scholarship that's like making 500 an hour that
is significant i mean what other part-time job
in high school are you gonna find that makes that
amount of money i decided i want to make looking
at scholarships like my full-time job if i just
hit one of those 500 scholarships after applying
for 10 of them it's still worthwhile so much of
it is about habits and just getting in a groove
of consistently putting in the effort it doesn't
have to be so overwhelming if you just break it
down into manageable steps you may have to
come home spend two hours spend three hours
on the internet grinding you may get a lot
of no's but that one yes that second yes
that third yes is going to be worth all the no's
that you got scholarships are a great opportunity
there are millions of scholarships given away
every single year for so many different reasons
you can win a scholarship for
being tall for being short
there's a vegetarian scholarship there's a
scholarship for being a golf caddy for having the
best zombie apocalypse escape plan the criteria is
so broad that it's a numbers game in many senses
don't write off the 500 scholarship don't
write off the thousand dollar scholarship
because those are often where students find the
most success there were some i didn't find out
until the last second and there were some that
i got that i didn't even know i was going to get
if you were still enrolled in a university you
should still do your research and try to find
scholarships if you are currently taking
out student loans to get through school
take a moment to do some research and see
the vast options available where you do not
have set goals and you do not go through a
series of behaviors with intentionality you
are never going to be in that area of your life
successful and college is no exception to that
every single day you're being intentional
about the decisions that you make that's
going to get you in college and through
college without borrowing a dime
it sets in once you apply for graduation it's like
okay i will no longer be in school so i no longer
have that crutch of putting it off because now at
this point i am going to have to come up with a
plan as to when i'm going to start paying it back
off how much i'm gonna have to start paying back
off and what i can even afford to pay back off and
there's a bunch of stuff that come with adulthood
that you just don't account for it does kind of
make me worry about what am i going to do then
you know like i don't want to still be paying
back student loans when i'm supposed to be
nearing retirement but being realistic and
like looking at it's like well maybe i won't be
because 13 000 can turn into 25 000 easily
depending on how i manage that because it's a
lot of my peers who leave a four-year university
and still don't have a job for six months and
that's where you have to start paying back
your student loans so it's like what do you do
moving to van wert we tried buying a
home like it wasn't a very nice home but
it was in well means and we applied for loan and
got denied definitely like put us in perspective
like we would never get a house we wouldn't be
able to have kids like we're not going to be
able to live we had a point in time where we
actually did not go shopping for a full month
and we didn't have food outside of basically some
boxed pasta and like watered down spaghetti sauce
because we didn't we did not have
enough money to literally go afford
to buy groceries and that's with every credit
card maxed out everything like just literally
backs to the wall pinned up against it like we've
officially hit rock bottom i just looked back
at that money amount and realized like what what
did it actually get me i know it got me a college
degree and i know it got me experiences but the
college degree and experience is worth 125 000
we don't think anymore we just do so much of
our mental health challenges in this country
are because we let our feelings and our emotions
drive our day college choice is no different
we've gotten so unintentional about it and then
we figure out we're going to pay for it later
now we blinked there's a couple of trillion
dollars floating around out there on the backs
of 19 20 25 year olds 40 year olds it's
just becoming like a car payment like a
mortgage that's just a payment we have that's
a way of life and we've got to recenter that
so who's the first person on the schedule it's a
consult okay when i was 10 i got hit in the mouth
of the golf ball so it like broke my two
front teeth and unfortunately i was the
one that hit the golf ball so it came back
and hit me right in the mouth i was kind of
in and out of the dentist office as a kid so
that's what got me interested in orthodontics
i got out of undergrad debt-free but then
it uh quickly went the other direction
finished dental school i had probably
somewhere around 400 000 in in student loans
ortho and oral surgery are the
two most competitive residencies
and a majority of programs i mean they only have
three or four seats each year and they probably
have 1500 applications so i mean you have to be up
in the top of your class to even get an interview
all right you just got to stay biting
down to hold that in place for me okay
once i was in residency the
tuition was 95 000 a year
i mean at that point i mean what
i didn't have any other options
it was either you know you're not gonna be an
orthodontist or this is what you're gonna do
there is a quote-unquote bottomless pit of money
if you will i consider private loan folks the same
as payday lenders there's always a place to go
find money right it's going to cost you your soul
but there's money out there if you want to
go do the things you got to do to go get it
we're seeing private educational loans becoming
larger and larger and larger where there's no
real governmental control like there is under the
federal programs for those you're at the mercy of
your lender and for that i can't tell you what's
going to happen but you're at the mercy of a
private credit-based lender and you owe
tens of thousands of dollars good luck
think about it like a car payment you've agreed
this much money over this many months at this
much amount to pay it back when you don't we want
it give me your pound of flesh now and that pound
of flesh can come in all different ways but they
have to sue you to get that then you have now
a judgment against you that they can then do
other things for instance garnish a paycheck
if you have one garnish a bank account if you
have one you possess a vehicle if you own it
to be made whole because they light you money
what we also have to think about though with
that is roughly 90 of those are co-signers
so the co-signer could be mom or dad grandma
and grandpa is a huge one and there's nothing
worse sitting around thanksgiving table telling
grandpa you can't pay that and grandpa already
knows because he was served with a lawsuit too
we had borrowers with private student loans where
they would be paying their loan on time faithfully
and their like parent or grandparent who co-signed
their loans died and instantly despite the fact
they were paying they're like now you're in
default give us all give us all our money i
had someone she was in a horrific car accident
paralyzed her and um her mother was killed in
the car accident which triggered the default
on the private student loans she was hoping to
get back to work she was you know working for her
degree in nursing and she had a closed head injury
and i thought okay this this is the case
this is it we can do this um and the court
and that at the end of the day
because she was gonna qualify
most likely for on social security disability
that meant that she had the ability to pay it back
but i want to try to figure out how
to make stuffing i think if i add some
broth to it it won't be so good it won't
be dry yeah but we'll try it and see
one way to find out when it came to student
loans like you could get whatever you wanted
there's problems on both sides of that
the people that are giving the money and
the people that are taking the money
i mean 95 000 times 15 residents
you're talking 1.3 million
dollars in tuition from 15 people
and the international residents that were
there paid 140 000 in tuition every year 140.
you're you're a number you're you're a paycheck
and who you're surrounded by in those years
are people who probably know nothing about
personal finance have the same loans that you
have and you literally just you do everything
you can just to not even think about it it's not
like i'm getting a loan and they're giving me
the money and then i have to actually give it
to the school i never saw it it was scary but
at that point you're just like whatever man
with all the interest and everything that i
already had on my loans i probably had 500 or
600 000 i'm like sure just throw it on there
you want to go ahead and take
him back and do that okay
it's a ton of money and it is it's scary and i
think early on too it was just we had to have
like a lot of like hard conversations about it how
are we gonna pay it off do we just go on a minimum
repayment plan and you just pay it off for forever
like how do you even begin to get out of it
the people who are writing the loans and they
don't care i just got an offer on my student loans
like oh you qualified to lower your your interest
rate well why'd you wait till i have 300 000
in interest to lower my interest
rate why don't you lower it before
because you just wanted all the interest
these student loans you know they never go
away unlike so much other debt that can be
forgiven you know in the wake of a bankruptcy
for instance it's like stepping in gum man it's
with you forever and ever and ever so it is
accruing about 6 000 of interest every month
mr frostman you are now recognized for
five minutes to present your oral testimony
over the course of the last decade i traveled all
across this country talking to thousands of people
in big cities small towns and nearly every slice
of america in between and from these conversations
i have found that one aspect of life cuts across
the fallout from extraordinary student debt
there are now more than 8 million student
loan borrowers in default we had a million
student loan borrowers default last year a year
before that the year before that year before that
so if you do the math that means every 28 seconds
another student loan borrower defaults on its loan
on top of that we have three million more
borrowers who are behind that's over 10
million people or one out of four student loan
borrowers who are having their financial lives
ruined as they can't make their payments people
with student debt have just felt invisible
you take on debt that's what you're supposed to
do this is good debt stop complaining but the
ramifications for your financial life are the same
if not worse like student loan borrowers have less
rights less protections and we use the full weight
of the government to make sure you pay that back
i look at all the things that are going on
right here and i'm just article after article
what certainly seems like a very large amount of
corruption in 2009 sallie mae's ceo said quote
if a borrower can create condensation on a mirror
they need to get a loan this year in order to put
their subprime lending in place navien forwarded
wrong information to credit reporting agencies
saying that permanently disabled veterans
had defaulted on their loans when they hadn't
then you have itt credit union using financial
aid staff to rush students through an automated
application process when they knew that they
had projected default rates as high as 64
so they were setting people
up to fail these are a series
of public policy choices at the federal government
at the state government that have gotten us here
i think this is the intersection between so much
debt and illegal practices right because there's
this enormous mismatch between what borrowers are
promised and what's happening on the ground and in
between our student loan companies this is not
just some one-off company or like one bad apple
you see players across the student loan spectrum
who just view this as their chance to get wretch
my name is lynn sabolsky i am a former employee of
nadine's call center i thought it was going to be
a really easy straightforward job that i would
understand the rules that i would perform well
the longer i was there i started to notice red
flags people were being asked to lie people were
not being given the right information in general
there was just this oppressive environment that
wasn't really allowing the representatives
to do the job that they were being paid to do
there is a memo that navient council told and
had the mantra to the people that you would
call those customer service people for bear
for bear for bear get these people that way
forbearance an agreement to postpone your loan
payments while interest continues to accrue when
naviance puts an account in forbearance they
get to collect the interest those loan balances
increase they are now collecting interest on top
of interest that is the most beneficial scenario
for them we sued one of the biggest student
loan companies in the country navient and a
single claim as part of that lawsuit documented
how the practices of this company added 4 billion
with a b dollars of unnecessary interest onto the
most vulnerable borrowers mr fuhrman our friends
across the aisle have mentioned that student loan
services are supposedly not incentivized to steer
borrowers toward forbearance and that they are not
financially incentivized to give borrowers poor
or outright incorrect advice yet an audit released
by the doe in february this year found that more
than 60 percent of the department's oversight
report contained examples of servicers acting
improperly if our friends across the aisle are
correct and loan services are not incentivized
to make mistakes and give poor advice then why is
this consistently happening because they're wrong
because they are incentivized to give bad advice
they're incentivized to get their call reps off
the phone as quick as possible which we see across
the industry leading to the outcomes we have today
this part of our training was keeping your calls
to seven minutes if i don't keep my call to seven
minutes i have a lower status at the end of the
day i'm considered not having performed as well
if you're a representative and your choice is give
this person the help they need or get in trouble
in some way shape or form then really you're
you're pitting one person against the other
i was talking to my coworkers over lunch and over
break and a few of my co-workers said that there
was just no way to answer all of those questions
in a way that was satisfactory and maintain the
numbers that we were maintaining and so they
would be on their call and then they would
just press a button and go oops we're sorry dial
again funny enough navient's still in business
making a kajillion dollars a year and still has
contracts with the federal government angry yet
on the shoreline of maui's wailea beach at the
luxurious fairmont hotel sallie mae executives
and more than a hundred of its employees are on
a five-day paid trip celebrating a record year
5 billion in student loans to 374 000
borrowers planning session and recognition of
accomplishments for our sales force
has been something that has been done
i'm going to say since the company was founded
in 1972 and it's recognition of the hard work but
it's an important piece of planning i think we're
done that is like a general sentiment that we hear
frequently which is we love getting the money
to be involved in the student loan system
but when it actually comes to doing the work to
help borrowers to avoid the defaults you know
how dare you accuse us of of being part of the
problem and so we sued this company in court
and one of their top legal arguments
were judge you should dismiss
this case because we have no actual
responsibility to help followers
i'm being cheated out of my paycheck
i could retire two years after
i'm done paying my student loans
it's like paying for retirement and literally
never seeing a dime of it ever again
you should know the names of the companies that
have targeted your constituents citibank discover
bank navient fia quinn street sallie mae sofi
transworld wells fargo and the list goes on
in a way there's no morality in the student loan
system because there is no one that's going to
stop you from borrowing at the end of the day
it's just you know you type a couple buttons in
and on the other side there's a student loan with
some numbers that is the most personal it gets
so this right here is my uh college
diploma um don't even take it out of the
envelope in fact i had to have my mother mailed to
me because i didn't know where it was so let's see
stamped signed and sealed
that's not going to ever be framed i'm not going
to ever leave this envelope again and ensure i
can have the degree allows me to do something
that i love to do in but this piece of paper
is something that has brought a lot of pain
in my life i don't really want to look at it
you can talk to someone who's graduated
10 years ago and they still owe
student loans so it's like if
i can meet a complete stranger
and this is what we have in common that's an issue
the borrower slave to the
lender and like that's so true
when you have this kind of debt or
really any debt like you you feel that
it changes who you are and how you can behave
it changes your life
you've arrived at your destination the choices
that they made now own them and they were led
down this primrose path by a set of values put
on them by a series of guidance counselors and
parents who weren't thinking educators who were
out of control and a congress who continues
this ridiculous student loan debacle and here
they sit trapped and they do not know what to do
i try to do this without crying i feel like
when he told me how much shitload that he had
it wasn't gonna make me change
the way i felt about him like
you're dead is it bringing
you down as a person you know
millions of americans are struggling with the
same problem like it's not just your fault
i like i don't care how much diet he'll
ever have like i would still always love him
but i don't think he realized that
i feel like i've failed as the provider
as the husband because i'm the reason that
we're in so much debt we only had a total of
about 142 000 120 some of that is my college
it's literally like saying you're the reason
your team is losing if they if you weren't on
this team we'd be winning but because of
one thing it takes everybody down with it
the first hardest thing it was for me was
right after we got married we could not go on
a honeymoon and i know that sounds like cliche but
like you don't realize you'll never have that like
moment that like time again like newlyweds get to
go to like this awesome place like it's something
you look forward to when you get married and
like we lost out on like that time that was hard
i know she still loves me no matter what and
i'm so grateful for that but it stopped us from
being able to get a house when we moved
down to vane where and it stopped us
for a long time from not having kids like
i'm not being the man that i'm supposed to be
looking at you know what it's gonna look
like to actually attempt to to pay it off
paying somewhere around ten thousand dollars a
month you know sounds like it's gonna you know
actually do something but it's not gonna do
as much as you'd like to think that it will
at some point it's gonna have to be you
know you're paying 20 30 40 000 a month
to be able to pay 30 or 40 000 a month i mean
you gotta you gotta be making a lot of money
you know i think realizing you know what it
is um it just uh you know just knowing that
you know it's probably not going to be possible
you know without the help of god i mean
how am i gonna make that much money
but all you can do is try so
there are a lot of people who quite rightfully
say i did everything i was told to do now i'm
in a boatload of debt i'm not happy about
it how are we going to keep this cycle
from repeating itself well to the first group
of people i'm sorry that you shouldn't have
trusted the system the system let you down how
do we keep from repeating it is stop telling
people this is what they're supposed to do stop
telling people that this is the path it might be
easier it's definitely more fun in the short
run but here it is with subtitles this is not
what you're supposed to do what you're supposed
to do is figure out how to make a contribution
not figure out how to make a marketing industrial
governance system happy in the short run
what was the first step you took in terms of
you getting out the lifestyle that you were yeah
changed my mind what are you putting inside of
this that comes out of this that comes out of this
a degree that y'all are trying to get is
a small degree when it comes to your life
this right here is everything and when
i changed what i was putting up here
that's when my whole life changed each and every
single one of you all need to have a clear vision
of what you want to do the vision is not
i want to go to this school i want to have this
experience no what is the vision for your life
i want to have options i want freedom the question
is are you willing to put in the work up front
if you can grasp that you will be successful
going into my senior year i knew it would be close
i can do the math so can you working at a normal
hourly job would not pay the necessary 14 000 i
needed for school i knew what i had to do i went
for something with more opportunity and that was
a sales commission job and really went and made
the most of it usually work four days a week ten
hour shifts and then on my off days i would sell
lawn mowers and flip them driving across the state
hey how's it going good how about you good
it's right over here little did i know
that there was so much opportunity in it
well i know you had it listed for
six but just take five on it cash
we gotta teach young people how to
really take ownership of their life
if they're paying something out of their pocket
they will take their education experience a little
bit more serious because now they can say my
parents didn't pay for it we paid for it this is
just simplistic to me it's something i understand
and i don't think lawn mowers is for everybody
someone who's interested in shoes would
be better suited to do something like that
as long as you have knowledge in an area you can
probably figure out a way to make money with it
during this expensive period if you have the
resources and the time how will you choose to
spend it so that when the system tries
to squeeze you you can say no thank you
got these pictures uploaded gotta do
some cropping get them posted then wait
there was one guy i bought a bigger zero turn paid
1700 bucks brought it home washed it listed it
sold it for 2 600. same day my mom would just be
dumbfounded are you sure you're allowed to do that
mom it's selling lawnmowers i don't know what else
you want you definitely have a lot of noise around
you saying take out loans you're not able to do
this once you find that window of opportunity
though and realize that if you repeat this
process over and over like i did with lawn mowers
there's just so much empowerment and that feeling
of running after this goal and chasing it down and
putting everything you have into it that's hard
to explain all right she's all ready to go yep
when you start opening your eyes and
looking to these unique opportunities
you can add value in unique ways all good
in total that summer i probably made around 13 000
at that point i could say i'm getting
out of these four years debt-free
i don't know for a while to go here but we are
oh sweet
that's cool so i remember once when i was in
undergrad and i asked my history professor why
did they send all these 18 and 19 year old u.s
soldiers to the normandy innovation and he said
something that shook me he said because any combat
veteran who saw that plan would have said no way
d-day worked because of some extraordinary
planning some extraordinary sacrifice and what
he said was good old-fashioned unabated american
teenage arrogance because they got up in front and
told those boys nine out of ten of you will not
come home 90 out of 100 of you are not coming back
and those guys in line went sucks to be that
guy right and they did that all the way down
because when you're a teenager you're invincible
that's gonna happen to somebody else and so i have
to know no matter how honest i'm being and
how upfront i'm being hey this is expensive
and you're gonna have to pay this back i have to
know that my end consumer the 18 year old's going
okay we'll get there and has no understanding
of what seven hundred dollars a month actually
feels like out of a 2 400 a month paycheck i'm
just i feel like i'm just so worried about like
having to sacrifice my happiness for like a
cheaper route like having to sacrifice what really
makes me happy and brings you joy on a day-to-day
basis just to save money like happiness is worth
anything like you know what i mean like that's the
part i'm confused on like if you're not happy in
life at that given moment no matter what it takes
what does it really matter the happiness later on
i'm not saying you can't be
happy i want you to be happy
but i feel as if your happiness comes from
something that is outside of education
and i feel as if you're looking for something to
confirm something on the internal side of you not
something to help you grow as a man because if
you're looking for the education then you can get
the education anywhere but from what you said you
just want to go there so you can have a good time
i would really step back and
ask myself what's more important
happiness for four years that cost me 30. or
a little bit of happiness but hard work that
really makes me happy for the rest of my life and
if it was me i'm saying man i'm putting into work
i look back at my four years
and this is the time of my life
i got to travel a bunch for really cheap
been to alaska california texas florida
but the reality is it's not the buildings it's
not the sports it's not the land around the school
that make the experience that's all up to you
it's not the school that's gonna change that
so which one of these are you sitting i'm way
like over there you'll have to get your
binoculars out and squint a little actually
i did you know what the difference is between
a normal person and someone who is not normal
is the not normal person was willing to do the
things that normal people are not willing to do
i do not want to live the majority of my life not
being able to do what i want to do because i got
to pay for things in my past that's the normal i
refuse to be a part of students need to begin by
saying i refuse to be brainwashed into believing
that if i get into a good college it means i'm
better than if i don't so go find a door you can
afford and go through that door and figure out
how to marshal the resources you need whether it's
scholarships or only going part-time or taking a
gap year and working like crazy to put 25 000 in
the bank so at least your first year you're not
starting with free and easy money you're going
to be paying off for decades it never was the
degree that caused people to succeed it was the
knowledge base the tools in their belt to be able
to get their work done that's what caused people
to succeed it still is what causes people to
succeed whether you can demonstrate that you have
the skills to do the job is going to be a much
higher indicator than where you went to school
or for that matter even if you have the degree
i think there's a real opportunity for guidance
counselors and parents to talk to their kids
about how they want to work as opposed to what
they want to do i think a smarter thing to tell
a person who's trying to figure
out what to be when they grow up
is to say put it all on the table and if you do
that you're liable to be a very happy satisfied
plumber making six figures a year or perhaps
running your own mechanical contracting company
it's not the job that makes you happy it's you so
what this is really about is freedom it's about
earning the freedom to decide what you're going
to do next david james wilson bachelor of arts
business administration summa [__] laude here's
the secret to you while being successful you're
not looking at the picture today you're looking
at the end picture what kind of future do you want
and the choices you're making now will impact
it i can choose what opportunities i want i can
choose where i want to live i can decide my job
i can focus my time on things that matter to me
which will lead to greater satisfaction down
the road the best feeling is knowing that
this journey that i'm starting with the rest of
life i don't have to carry any baggage with me
can you imagine getting off that stage
going home walking into your job for the
very first time it's your career and when you
get that first paycheck that paycheck is yours
can you imagine having freedom
at 22 making 35 40 45 000 a year
walking the stage debt-free is not
just about walking the stage debt-free
but you're walking into life debt-free
welcome
and
so